امام هذه العيادات المتخصصه في معالجه
الحمى في شنغهاي وبكين ينتظر الصينيون
ساعات طويله هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا منذ
تخفيف قواعد في مطلع الشهر الجاري ارتفاعه
عدد المرضى اقلق مدير منظمه الصحه
العالميه
في الصين لاجراء تقييم كامل تحتاج المنظمه
الى معلومات اكثر تفصيلا حول خطوره المرض
والحالات التي ادخلت المستشفيات ووحدات
العنايه المركزه المنظمه لن تتوانا عند
دعم الصيني لتركيز الجهود على تلقيح
الاشخاص الاكثر عرضه الخطر
الشوارع والاماكن السياحيه شبهه خاليه
الفيروس لم يعد خطيره لكنهم يعتنون
بانفسهم ولا يخرجون انظروا بامكانك ان
تتجول بحريه في صامته
مع رفع القيود الصارمه بشكل مفاجئ تقدير
منظمه الصحه العالميه ان يصباح وليس 800
مليون صيني بالكرونه هذا الشتاء